I thank you for coming I'm reminded of
when I come to Yale of Groucho Marx who
said I would never want to belong to any
club that would take me as a member I'm
the reverse of that I love to come to a
place that wouldn't would not take me as
a member i have had a wonderful day here
at Yale and and I want to thank helen
classy and keeani and and the president
for inviting me here to come here
because of of this pointer fellowship
Nelson pointer Yale graduate and a force
behind a great newspaper at the st.
Petersburg Times which was a training
ground for many journalists that I know
and he was also the creator of the
Poynter Institute for Media Studies I'm
honored to be on the list that includes
people like Bob Woodward my friend and
others in fact I've been going around
New York and and I'll say to people your
Nobel Lord right and they'll say yes and
I say I'm a point of fellow at Yale a.m.
and the two are comparable I will tell
them I Bob Woodward is a is a is a
wonderful guest if you do what I do you
want people like Bob Woodward who I know
as a proud graduate of this university
he once said to me after I was
interviewing him he said you know a lot
of people can speed-read you speed here
and I can just I can hear you getting to
you know ready to go and you grabbed my
mind and you take it around and and I
never know where you're going to go with
me where I want to go with somebody like
Bob would what is what makes him tick or
John Kennedy once said that once if
after the presidency he thought he'd go
into journalism because it was about
what makes people tick and and the
interesting thing about Bob Woodward is
that that he has this amazing ability to
get you to tell your story to him and he
has this amazing
technique in which if there are five
people in the room he'll get to one
who's probably known for 20 years in
Washington and that person will tell him
and then go the other person's they
already know and then that person will
since he knows I might as well tell him
everything and by the end of about five
of those he does have the story this has
been for me as a journalist an
incredible week if you do what I do
there was first a done I'm a story last
week which told us something about
ourselves and then on Monday we had this
incredible tragedy at VP I they both
these stories told us something about
our culture and the need to resist
coarseness and physical and verbal
violence and we need to talk about it
but it also told us something about
handguns in our society what they've
asked me to talk about today or
questions the one ones that we ask in
the ones that we should ask I must tell
you that that there are a few interviews
that I do that I don't think of a
question that I wish I'd asked or don't
don't look at an interview and say to
myself I wish I'd followed up rather
than going where I took that
conversation that is the nature of what
we do it is a conversation and it is
live George will once said the best two
things on television our conversation
and sports because you do not know where
they're going they are not scripted
friend of mine named Diane Sawyer said
that interviewing is like tennis the
most important interviewing technique is
listening and you listen the way that an
athlete waits for the ball you ready to
move in this direction are you ready to
move in that direction and you listen
without self-consciousness and you
listen without self-importance and you
listen as a human being first as a human
being first and you listen as a pursuer
of the facts second and you never listen
as a television personality one of my
favorite questions is to simply ask as
we talk about questions is to simply ask
people what questions should we be
asking or what would you say
if you were talking to the president say
I said that to Bill Maher the comedian a
couple of nights ago and he said I would
ask the president what did you know
about Iraq before you committed this
country to an invasion think about it
the interview is at the heart of
journalism it's combined with an ability
to express and to analyze and to observe
it is this interview at the core of what
all of us do we have to add these other
things but what is important about it in
my judgment is that it has not changed
some argue that the high point of
interviewing was in the 1950s and the
1960s when you had the paris review
interviewing writers all over the world
or you had Playboy magazine or you had
the New Yorker and then the 50s and the
sixes and that interviews were used at
that time to put the focus on the
personality of cultural and political
figures I say to you that the interview
is the one thing that technology and the
expansion of the media has not changed
almost everything has changed but the
interview this core thing that is at the
heart of journalism what has changed for
those of us in journalism is access and
participation the access that we have to
information and the access that me as a
journalist and the access that people
have to participate in the process think
about VPI I mean there were people on
cell phones communicating their that day
it is the new phenomenon in terms of
tragedy wherever it is there are people
there who are doing their own reporting
and they're communicating to CNN or to
Fox News or other places and it's on the
air because they are the only observer
in the case of epi there was a search to
get the interview with students with
police with administrators with experts
and with politicians we all wanted to
know what an interview always wants to
know who what when where and why
what we still don't know about that kind
of tragedy is context we don't know and
it is always a toughest thing to know we
don't know why we beginning to get some
insight we're beginning to see that
their records left and notes left and
we're beginning to know that people had
some kind of experience and they made
judgments and we understand it a little
bit about the why but in the society we
live in it takes a lot more there is
always the drive in interviewing to find
someone who will tell you and tell you
first I remember as a young reporter at
NBC News I went to cover they picked up
in one of these little planes in the
middle of the night to go to West
Virginia to where they had been a
disaster to mind and we stood around and
and the families were standing around
and it's the it's the most emotional
experience you can have because first of
all you don't know what's happened you
just know they didn't come back and you
got these people who who live in this
community who appreciates the danger and
fear the moment that they're living and
I remember for me trying to understand
and report back for NBC for the Today
Show the next morning a man just said to
me we found a cigarette lighter they had
been an explosion we found a cigarette
lighter I knew that first it was an
information that i know and journalists
always want to do that what forces are
at work in our society as we ask why
what is it that we know about this
gunman at virginia tech what do we know
about why we do what we do and what it
is that makes us tick I'm just going to
give you a moment of biography about me
because I've been asked this question
since I've been on this campus at noon
and I just want to say a couple of
things i have this remarkable job that
that i have and is remarkable because it
gives me the opportunity to do things
and it is a trust that i believe i have
with you and with the guests and to take
it seriously but i feel so lucky that i
grew up in a place in a small town in
america in North Carolina where my
curious
city was what it was that enable me to
be a participant because my parents
owned a little small country store and
that store where I was asked by my
father as fathers asked you to do
something you will be here tomorrow
morning at eight o'clock and i had a
chance to live there over the weekend
and work and the nice thing was that it
had a shaping influence for the rest of
my life because I live with adults I had
to meet people at their own level and I
began to ask them questions which was a
bond and they began to understand me and
I began to appreciate what was the
currency of conversation I went on from
that to go to Duke and to go to law
school to go to New York and then all of
a sudden because of curiosity to be
asked to do what I do now and the fact
that I've had people who have helped me
along and who recognize that i wrote a
mission statement about for 14 years ago
and which I expressed to my group that
started out then what this show is going
to be about and I said to them at that
time what we are about you know as Don
Hewitt used to say about 60 minutes for
reporters go tell a story for words 60
minutes was about go tell a story and
what we are going to do is tell a story
through the interview and we want to
find the mystery of the human condition
if we want to find what makes people
tick we want to find what events mean
and that's what we have been doing and
what I have been doing for most of my
adult life and I have profited from it
Hansen tlie handsomely not just because
of the money and the rewards it has and
the celebrity especially not but because
i have had a chance to be in touch
within a daily way with the big ideas
and the interesting people and the fears
and the hopes of a community that i
inhabit and the people who come there
come from science and they come from
business and they come from politics and
they come from art and it come from
sports and they come from entertainment
and what they do is bring their own
experiences and I have enjoyed their
company and I have done things that I
would never have
done except for journalism and except
for the fact that I was able to somehow
bring the idea of the interview to a
different place to eleven o'clock at
night in an hour conversation with the
most interesting people that there was
it has enabled me to to watch soccer at
an apartment in in Tel Aviv with your
chakra beam you know to go around a
racetrack with Michael Schumacher to
play basketball with Charles Barkley and
tennis with andre agassi to do a whole
range of things that i would not have
been able to do to have Harold Pinter
listen to me read his own poetry and
make a judgment as to whether I did it
well or not so well and I have learned a
few lessons along the way and I have
made a few rules of the road for the
essence of the interview and and I share
them with you in a sense that we can
talk about them later it always begins
with who what when where why those are
the questions that we ask every day it
can bring you extraordinary results I
saw over the weekend 60 minutes do an
interview with the three young Duke
Lacrosse students and players and team
members who had just been told by the
Attorney General North Carolina that all
charges have been dismissed and that
they were innocent and Lesley Stahl from
60 minutes said to one of those young
men if you could talk to the prosecutor
what would you want to ask him and he
said without fail why and it is the
question it's the question that Roger
Mudd asked of edward kennedy in 1979
when he wanted to be President Roger
Mudd said why do you want to be
President the inability of Senator
Kennedy who has been an extraordinary
senator to have an answer that was in
any way giving voice to what senator
Kennedy at that time understood about
what he wanted to the present doomed his
presidential Kansas chances or at least
was the beginning of that experience for
him I remember that when dan Rather said
to President Clinton why President
Clinton said because I could which said
a lot about about
the circumstances of that I remember so
many times that when you asked this
question why that's all you need to do
to have almost a complete interview I
have some rules of this core interview
as what it means to journalism and the
way that I practice it first of all I'll
just give them quickly psychology of the
individual is so crucial to understand
where they are coming from to understand
as much as you can about them to
understand what is shaped them and why
they are there and what they might want
to express and how do you not only untap
that but also how do you ask them make
them get them to want to justify what
they have done secondly as all of us
know and because I said this earlier
about tennis it is preparation one of
the things that I miss most is more of
an opportunity to prepare for these
interviews I do a show five nights a
week I do a lot of other things like
this and and I haven't remarkable staff
of people that are brighter than I am
but if there's anything than I do
because there is joy in the preparation
there is joy and learning everything you
can it's the same reason people come to
a university community to learn and
that's what is exciting as actually
doing it preparation preparing for a
game for a match and athlete if you're
an athlete or if you're an actor is
never never quite as satisfying as being
on stage testing what you have learned
but it is something that adds to how
well that experience will be the other
thing is listen and you all know what
that means but it is not just to hear
but to listen to have your sense of
listening so attuned so that you can
hear the nuance so that you are not
simply listening to an answer seize the
moment is crucial an interview like a
sporting event may go off in any
direction you never imagined and you
have to hear that moment and you have to
seize it and you are able to do that
because you have prepared another thing
is to read the person that comes from
the psychology there is also
imperative that many people don't
understand or appreciate in terms of
what i see it is to engage it is based
on all the other things make sure that
you engage so that something is
happening in this moment that you have
together so that you are taking that
person as Bob Woodward said dragged
across the stage you're taken that
person to somewhere they haven't been
you have to have a strategy you have to
have on the part of the person who's
doing as Diane Sawyer said in that
opening quote that i read a genuine
desire to understand and to learn to be
receptive you have to know how to follow
up there has to be always if it's going
to be good spontaneity I remember there
was a famous writer that all of you know
and I wrote this down some when I stop I
have it here and I frequently use this
as my fallback plan when i'm doing an
interview it is a series of questions
and i want you to think of these as I
repeat them these are the famous Proust
questions which which famously were used
by a guy in Paris who'd had a very
popular show on Friday night and and
these are some of the questions and what
I want you to do as you hear these
questions and thinking about an
interview at the core of a journalistic
experience what what should these
questions would you like to ask of the
following people Freud the president
this University Rick Levin Shakespeare
Einstein Stalin or Hitler or somebody
else who is evil or political leadership
of today vice president president these
are the profs questions what do you
regard is the lowest depth of misery
where would you like to live to what
false do you feel most indulgent what
are your favorite heroes of fiction what
are your favorite characters in history
who is your favourite heroine what are
your favorite painters who are your
favorite musicians what are the
qualities you most admire and a man or a
woman your favorite virtue or your
favorite occupation what would you like
to
have been your most marked
characteristic the guilt the quality you
most like in a man the quality you most
like in a woman what are you most value
your friends what is your principal
defect favorite application dream of
happiness with mine at what to your mind
would be the greatest of misfortunes
what would you like to be what country
would you like to live then there's a
whole series of those that I don't quite
understand favorite color favorite
flower favorite bird favorite animal
then it gets to be the favorite prose
writers favorite poets favorite hero
fiction think about the people I said we
want to ask these questions off and what
it might tell about them and their
character favorite poets favorite hero
fiction they would heroines of fiction
composes painters and all that and goes
and on and on and and these are the
questions that when everything else
fails if you do what I do those are the
questions that you hope will somehow
unlock this person because we all know
and which makes interviewing as
interesting most people like to talk
about themselves we know that from
dinner parties you know and what you do
is try to find a way that untapped that
you know I have my own list which is
different from Prowse which is asking
somebody sitting next to you asking if
somebody you can't unlock their own
passion to ask about their self-image
their obsessions their earliest memories
their achievements actually as I read
these I like mile is better than Proust
how would you describe what it last
lecture epitaph fundamentals of success
plan secret tells conflicts in your life
what makes you tick who's had a profound
impact what events with cherish moments
what dark moments with favorite book
movie painting would have been the
critical turns in your life if you're in
trouble who do you call if you didn't do
this what would you do who would you
like to meet and what would you like to
change about your life and just think
about that wouldn't you love to hear
those people speaking on those subjects
well that's what the essence of this
interview is and as you go and try to
make this interview speak to the subject
of the day what's interesting to me as
we think about an interview today is
that on television has added this
dimension which was not true in print
there is an element of perform
and the performance as I see it which
makes interviewing have impact is
engagement it is I contact it is body I
mean I find myself frequently clean
leave it leaning across my table and in
doing that it sends some message to the
person sometimes you can see them move
back like this where the hell are you
going you know reminds me of that
favorite favorite to photograph that the
New York Times cells of Lyndon Johnson
towering over senator green giving him
the Johnson treatment there is a variety
of forms of what we talked about and and
you know they're people that I admire
who do what we do there is Bill Moyers
as Mike Wallace and there's EDD Bradley
and Barbara Walters and Ted Koppel and
larry king and james lipton and Terry
Gross certainly on the radio and people
who no longer on television like Dick
Cavett and William Buckley are people
that have that have had an opportunity
to do this and have decided that there
were other things that they wanted to do
for whatever reason they're also the
show's chris matthews Bill O'Reilly
Keith Oberman Anderson Cooper the big
idea night lime they're all the Sun your
programs what you know about there is
perhaps one interview that maybe in my
lifetime the most famous interview of
all time it is now a Broadway play on
Broadway obviously and it comes to a
very successful run in London it is
called Frost and Nixon it is a story of
what David Frost did as he faced the
opportunity of engaging Richard Nixon
with the purpose of this engagement in
his mind to get in Richard Nixon to
confess and to get Richard Nixon to to
say I'm sorry this is what I did wrong
you know and this is how I have come to
accept it as this play will show you
things we're not going well for the
frost/nixon interview Nixon was in his
own inimitable way because he was a
bright professional politician was able
to deflect and David Frost were growing
in this conversation over a period of
four days in like 20 hours of
conversation more and more frustrated
and more and more unable to unable to
get anything so that his staff was in
fact at that point beginning to get
extraordinarily short with him and there
was one final interview they had agreed
to save what a gate to the end and so
frost went in that mrs. will see this in
the play frost went in that day knowing
that he had to rescue this interview
because first of all he'd put his own
money on the line his own reputation was
on the line and Nixon had said to frost
one of us will emerge from this as the
victor and so frost basically took the
position that he had to make it happen
you know and he does because they found
in the research some point but what
happened there and this is about
interviews if you I read the transcript
last night it is an interview in which
frost comes through finally not being
David Frost a talk show host but diing
David Frost who was genuinely curious
about this and genuinely had convinced
Richard Nixon through the persistence
and not short questions that he had to
level with himself so that as you know
Richard Nixon finally said the answer
that Frost one in which was I made
mistakes that I have impeached myself
and that I have I have nobody to blame
and that I have left not only left let
myself down and let my family down but I
have let America down that is probably
the most famous interview of all time
you can now see the frost/nixon play on
Broadway and it is a fascinating sense
of what it is done badly at the
beginning and not because frost didn't
want to do it well and then done
superbly well at the end and getting the
results which he wanted which was a
sense that Nixon
in a sense was being honest with himself
when I talk about interviews like this
there's some I have to tell you that the
biggest misconception and it pervades
journalism as we know it today it is
that there is a hard interview and
there's a soft interview there are hard
and soft interviews but the
misconception I think is one of them
issues that divide us when somebody
calls their show hardtalk my suggestion
to you is that you don't expect hard
talk because in Chris Matthews who's a
friend of mine two calls the show
hardtalk hard talk that's not what's
good about Chris Matthews that it's hard
talk because it's not that much harder
or that hard at all and this
misconception pervaiz and that's the
reason people want to call their shows
hard and that's why they want a
reputation as being hard chris matthews
is brilliant at what he does in politics
because somehow he understands the
poetry of politics and he's able to ask
questions that bring those sense of
motivation and what makes people tick to
his stage tim russert has been called by
some america's toughest sunday
interviewer he is not that he is
something more important Tim Russert
gathered around him on Sunday of last
week four or five people to talk about
the meaning of the ayahs controversy and
what came out of that meaning of that no
controversy was a sense that America
needed to ask itself questions about it
where how it allowed a certain
coarseness and crudeness and racism and
a capacity to hear things and not do
anything about it because your mind was
focused on other things I once was going
to do a piece in context of this called
you know Mike Wallace is a tough
interviewer in other myths about
television mike is perhaps the person in
American journalism who's done more with
the interview in terms of the longevity
of his career in terms of the kinds of
stories he has done and in certainly
what has happened to 60 minutes and what
is what he has meant to them
Mike Wallace will tell you the best
interview he has ever done was not with
the Shah of Iran which he's proud of was
not with the Ayatollah Khamenei which he
is proud of was not with Ronald Reagan
or Nancy Reagan or all the political
figures he the interview he's favored
that his favorite interview of all time
is with Horowitz because Horowitz first
of all hadn't played for 20 years hadn't
talked for longer you know and Mike was
able to find the poetry in Horowitz's
life at Bradley at 60 minutes same thing
if you ask it Bradley the late at
Bradley what was your favorite interview
and we talked about this on my show he
said Lena Horne he said let me tell you
a story he's there when I go to heaven
which is where I'd like to be you know
and God looks to me and he says to me
what have you done or she says to me
what have you done for admission he said
I'm going to say to god did you see my
Lena Horne interview Mike Wallace again
this is about interviewing Mike Wallace
says I want my epitaph to be tough but
fair tough but fair that is the essence
of what we ought to be doing being tough
but fair toughness is an interview
quality that I admire the best at that
was Oriana Falacci Henry Kissinger once
said of an interview he did which I'll
read to you in a moment it was the most
disastrous interview I ever had here was
what he said that made him so
embarrassed he was she got him to talk
about his role what what it was that
represented Henry Kissinger's at that
time he was called Super K by newsweek
magazine and a big story kissin just
said the main point arises from the fact
that I've always acted alone Americans
like that immensely in a short a Western
this amazing romantic character suits me
precisely because to be alone has always
been part of my style or if you like my
technique
he should never have said that or in a
Falacci not because she wanted to get
him but because she wanted him to reveal
himself created and ambience created an
environment used the interview to and
get Henry to say that Henry Kissinger
also famously said about Sally Quinn a
wife have been Bradley a reporter in a
very good reporter for The Washington
Post he once said about Sally who writes
profiles of which interviews are only
part he said a lot of times when people
write a profile about me I want to kill
them I want to murder them when sally
quinn writes a profile about me I want
to kill myself or Anna Falacci wrote
interviews that had impact they made a
difference in the way we'd see our
public life she once interviewed in
President or Pakistan indira gandhi when
she saw the transcript refused to meet
with him refused to meet with the
president pakistan in order to sign this
nuclear agreement they're people who
believe that Falacci and wallace and
lots of other great interviewers Dick
Cavett was very good David Frost is
still with us is now anchoring for Al
Jazeera television represent decades ago
that in fact when Oriana Falacci died in
1977 it was the end of the art of the
interview that it died with us I am I
liked her she used to call me up and say
a lot of nice things to me and I was the
one person that she wanted to interview
her but I and so I have said I have no
one that I think respects oriental more
and to see the interview that she did
with the Shah which I will tell you now
she went this is an example of why I
admired her she was interviewing shop
around and she said when I try to talk
about you here in Tehran people look at
themselves in a fearful silence they
don't even pronounce your name your
majesty what is that
the Shah said in response out of it out
of an excess of respect I suppose
Falacci said I'd like to ask you if I
were an Iranian instead of an Italian
and I lived here and thought as i do and
wrote as i do i mean if i were to
criticize you would you throw me in jail
the Shahs said probably that says it all
it was tough it was fair it was real and
he felt compelled to say something
important I I'm not even considered to
be the kind as tough as oriental Falacci
is you know and I am not even considered
to be as tough say as Mike Wallace is I
think all those judgments are wrong for
better or worse here's an interview I
recently did with Nicolas Sarkozy who
wants to be president of France this is
me some say you're dangerous they
worried about you as a president he
answers I respond but there's one poll
one very good poll today in Paris it
says you're ahead 54 to 46 but there are
also polls that say that 51 @ % of the
French people are afraid why is that I
said what is about you that leads the
French to say I'm afraid he offers an
explanation i said but you've heard it
before that you're dangerous that they
don't they want the change that you
promised but they worry about the kind
of man you are the other kinds of
interviews beyond these that we have
been talking about beyond the idea of
political interviews or they get just
run through some people that reflect of
a rate variation of the celebrity
interview Oprah and barbara walters and
dinosauria all the morning shows
magazine shows do it it is this idea as
Bob Schieffer once said that get the
right people at the right time that's
become that today has become it's true
for magazines to get the right person on
the cover of Vanity Fair get the right
person on the
cover Avvo get the right person on the
cover of your magazine that's become a
kind of game that is to celebrity
oriented and has caused us to lose
something in the process what's missing
most of all about the interview in
journalism today is not celebrity
interviews and it's not tough interviews
and it's not interviews with newsmakers
and is not all the things that we can
see what's missing today is the is the
idea of conversation people engaging in
each other of people having a dialogue
with each other that is the essence of
of what's come out of the ayahs question
Moyer's used to do it Cavett did it to
agree in terms of entertainment
conversation today has become almost an
overused word politicians say I want to
have a conversation with the American
people even French politicians ségolène
royal before she announces I want to go
out and have a conversation with the
French people and see what they think
America needs to have a conversation
about important ideas and because
conversations are by nature not about
sound bites not about two minutes they
have found a decreasing Avenue to be
seen on television I am part of the
process that believes conversations
belong on television conversations about
who we are but also conversations about
who people are you know and you can't do
that in five minutes and it's not best
done in my judgment using the interview
at its maximum 60 minutes for example
where they have been extraordinary
pieces and I was a proud member of that
staff it is a highly edited process it
takes the life out of something that is
very real about the interview about this
interchange between two people I'll talk
more about conversations but I want to
just say a couple of things about what
Rick Levin said and what was said
earlier because
members of the fryer family are here
Rick Levin said that we would hope and
expect that these lectures will focus on
the ethical responsibilities of those
engaged in government higher education
and communication that will continue the
conversation that Gary always encouraged
among his friends and colleagues about
how to be honorable ethical and
effective in all the various modes of
public service most of us know what Gary
meant it meant to be show integrity it
meant to show some sense of judgment it
meant to recognize the difference in
right and wrong I want to add one small
or a large dimension to what I think it
means to engage in a moral and ethical
dimension it means to act with some
sense of respect for the role that you
have been given and to take that and to
cherish the time that you have to do
your homework to church a time to listen
to do what Mike Wallace said be tough
but fair to take no cheap shots to
realize that not everything has two
sides but you have to find out if there
is another side that is worthy of
hearing you have to avoid agendas you
have to accept excellence and you have
to talk about what is the right thing to
do you have to appeal to people's hopes
rather than their fears yet at the same
time you have to understand what it is
in pursuing the level of ethic ethical
responsibility and moral responsibility
you have to understand what it is that
is required of you and what the
standards are that you set one of the
one of the favorite things that I
remember from sports is that Joe
DiMaggio was going to play in st. Louis
and he was still even though the Yankees
had won the pennant and they were
playing the st. Louis Browns and it was
near the last week of the of the pennant
race they've already won and Joe
DiMaggio was showing the same enthusiasm
the same energy the same love for the
game even though he could not did not
play that day and somebody came up and
said Joe you won the pennant this game
is meaningless why are you showing the
same energy and the same passion and the
same commitment to this sport and he
said there may be one person in this
stadium who has never seen Joe DiMaggio
play and I want him to see Joe DiMaggio
at his best and our responsibility to
very fryer as we do what we do is try to
make sure that people see us see us in
what we do at our best I just want to
take a few minutes to talk and did I
want to open this up to question a few
minutes to talk about the Don Imus story
and and what I think about it and also
VPI I remember when I just began a life
in journalism very wise editor told me
this story he said to me you know there
was once a cub reporter who was sent by
the Metropolitan editor to go cover the
school board and when he arrived at the
venue for the school board to cover the
story the school board the school itself
had burned down so it comes back to his
editor and he says and editor says
where's the story he said I don't have a
story you don't have a story why don't
you have a story I don't have a story
because the school burned down so I
think it would be remiss of me not to
talk a minute about the Imus story and
what it meant and what it says it was on
the front page of every newspaper
Newsweek and Time the cover story this
week is Don Imus Tim Russert said of his
show last week when he gathered people
around to talk about it he said I
intended to talk about Alberto Gonzalez
who was testifying this week this was
last Sunday but this story just seemed
to be too important all of it a story of
how dawn and three words put his career
in focus and on hold I must once did an
hour on my show and and I make this as a
poner disclosure
about him I had never been have never
been on a show it never asked to be on a
show obviously will never be on his show
he came to my show and he did an hour
with mean he went on the radio in the
next morning and I had no idea what it
was saying he said you know bar none
this is the best interview in my heart
filled with pride that done I must the
famous Don Imus had come to to do my
show and he went back the next morning
and talked about it for two or three
hours billet fans and until his staff
finally said just shut up we don't want
to hear about Charlie Rose anymore but
that was in that a sense of my own point
of the scrote discover discovery he said
a lot of other things later I'm sure
that I don't remember as well I was
never part of the inner circle and I
never tried to be but I had other things
to do not because I didn't might not
have wanted to but there is this to be
said about it it was a mark of
identification to be on Don ibises show
everyone wanted to be there they wanted
to be part of the inner club all those
people now including Don Imus agrees
that the remarks were indefensible they
were races and there was sexual slur
that hurts some very very special and
heroic people the Rutgers women's team
here org because they had gone a lot
further than anybody ever thought
because of their skill but also because
of their heart and their moment of
victory even though Tennessee beat him
in the end was clear to everybody and
then at their moment of victory they
hear this its translated to him a
Washington Post editorial said though
that this is more than a story about Don
Imus and his program and what has
happened to him it didn't take too long
the Post said for the debate to move
from racist and misogynistic musings to
gangsta rap its artists and the record
companies that helped hateful words and
negative images of women and African
Americans get into the mainstream we can
on this story and what's happened make
too much of it or we can make too little
of it it is not the first time that
there was an atmosphere that failed to
take on a television programs radio of
television program this time
that failed to take note of racism and
sexism for whatever reason too many
times in her life and work we failed to
stop this is our moral accountability
that Gary friar might remind us we fail
to stop and say I will not let that pass
I will not participate even though I
understand I understand it would be easy
for me to I can just ignore it i can say
it wasn't me i can sort I didn't say
that i can say wasn't part of what i was
doing we now know that in that program
there was a history of remarks and lots
of politicians and media stories you
know had done nothing and they've all
stepped forward to say that they didn't
step they stepped forward now because it
was impossible not to because somebody
had said this is not what we want on
radio and television these kind of
racist slurs somebody finally said that
in terms of anybody and therefore people
have been part of a program as guest
felt compelled to say what they thought
and to understand and explain the
benefit that they had received from that
you heard from all them and you saw them
when they participated online hit the
show was live you were thrilled to be
invited you were admired by your
colleagues it meant that you had
currency and it meant that that you were
a player and Don it should be said was a
star and he was a guy that you viewed
with affection and with amusement he was
this multifaceted human being with
interest and it was a small price to pay
if on another day there was criticism
about him here is the problem that I
worry about in terms of what we are and
what we do it is the notion it is the
notion that today that last week and on
Sunday everybody said we have to have a
conversation we have to have a dialogue
we have to do something about this this
has exposed us to our crudeness this is
exposed as to our coarseness this is
exposed as to something that doesn't
belong in a
country in a nation that believes as we
do about ourselves and there were all
kinds of people saying you know that we
have to have a national debate don imus
should be part of that national debate
that lots of people should be part of
that national debate then came Monday
and Monday there was another more deadly
more deadly extraordinarily violent and
tragedy and all of a sudden our focus as
it should be was there you know I worry
and I wonder that what we thought about
last week and what that as part of our
world and in the context of a
responsibility for your father and your
husband Gary's son and husband and wife
that what we have to do is remind
ourselves as we go on that the we've got
to insist on these dialogues we have to
assist that that the interviews that we
do play a part in a national
conversation about who we are I close
with this because I want to take your
question and I worry I worry that that
we will not have that dialogue and I
worry that that somehow we will not be
able to go forth I think that the age of
the interview not only is not over I
think that we need to demand more of it
and we need to demand more of ourselves
I read you as I close this something
that my colleague Ted Koppel's said ten
years ago this was ten years ago at a
commencement speech 12 years ago at a
commencement speech at Johns Hopkins and
I just happened to find this in my
library last night it's what he said 11
we should treat one another with respect
and courtesy regardless of race gender
creed or economic standing not because
the law or even the enforcers of
political correctness demanded because
it is illogical and self-destructive to
do otherwise unless and until we
perceive stability to be in our common
interest our national pendulum will
swing wildly between anarchy and
authoritarianism every murder every mug
in every rate
every robbery every criticism is further
evidence of the collapse of civility but
so too is the avalanche of legislation
which we have tried to replace it I know
we can't dispense with all of our laws
but I think how many of them would
become irrelevant if we were merely
treated one another with common courtesy
Alma he's continues what I find so
appealing about the notion is that it
lies within the capacity of each of us
to implement it just consider it please
that from the best of who we are is a
journalist head couple and it just
reminds me and the last two weeks remind
us that there is never more of an
imperative to do that to regain our
sense of purpose and civility and and
that the imperative for journalists and
people who have the national focus
people who have the capacity to bring us
together not forget not being a room
where things that happen that we don't
particularly like that we not forget
that we can use this instrument that we
have been given access to to make a
difference and make the world that we
live in better I am honored to be with
you to share a few thoughts with you and
to take your questions I am honored to
be here and to be with the for our
family for which this and as I said this
is the only way I've ever gotten to Yale
thank you very much